[Music]
I'm Mattie Andrea and this is car
collectors
[Music]
I've Bachmann on the vice president of
Galvan Motors and president of Galvin
Autosports we've got 50 cars or so here
and you'll notice they're from many
different genres and many different
styles I guess if there's any one theme
that runs through is that we love
customs amen okay good to see it too
thank you for inviting me over to the
Galvin Autosport collection there's so
many great cars here let's talk about
some of your hot rods
tell me about ed Roth I grew up a custom
cars so to me kind of the wilder the
better and I look at where car
customizing came from who inspired
culture and it all comes down to Big
Daddy raw I mean what he did was really
transform cars into art so of all the ed
Roth parts which one is your favorite
hands-down orbit Ron and I know this one
has a great story great story on bedrock
built orbit Ron in 1964 and he wanted to
have an asymmetrical design with some
new technology in it the new technology
was color television in the day so the
idea was to have a red green and blue
light but as they shone together it
would be one white light and of course
with the bubble top the monkey for the
television you know this was a real show
car now oddly this is one of his
failures that he considered and he
blamed it squarely on the Beatles
because he said kids stop take caring
about cars and they just picked up
guitars let's take a look at some of the
other rock cars all right and this is
wrote our or the Roth air car it's a
hovercraft and it actually flew back in
the day in 1962 he flew this a car shows
it doesn't work right now it's pretty
dangerous extremely it must have been a
blast at the time just the idea of being
able to try to create and there was this
whole wave of hovercrafts would be the
next car of the future so much for that
idea
and this is mysterion now this is a
clone
because the real mysterion was actually
destroyed but this was Ross wildest car
it's very alien like it was the first
like real asymmetrical car it just makes
no sense no one has ever done anything
like this before twin-engine you know
bubble-top blue with monkey fur interior
it's completely insane
the idea i love it tell me about these
two cars you got these two together here
well this is the ice truck in the milk
truck they were built by Dan woods
actually who was kind of a protege and
who eventually went to go work for Big
Daddy Roth building a lot of his cars
and I know you're working on another car
they don't have here now it's a 34 for
yes but a lot of that has this influence
into it right yeah the way we don't have
here is our 34 Ford which is just
unbelievable it's one of the wildest
paint jobs that you'll ever see all the
glass is actually blue plexi even on the
engine compartment transmission you can
see through it it's got a massive
Thunderbolt engine in it it just sounds
like the world's coming to an end when
you start it up and it's literally
perfect bow thank you so much an
absolute pleasure got such a great car
collection your hot rods especially are
absolutely amazing for even more great
videos to subscribe to G Q calm and
don't forget let us know what you want
to see on car collectors